Yeah, this is like actually kind of real.
MSG is magic.
It's truly magic.
And there's all this idea that, like, it's
like, bad for you or whatever, but it’s
just not.
That’s like, a lot of that's just fake.
But, I did this like whole deep dive on MSG
because I like to eat Doritos for breakfast.
Like who doesn't like Doritos for breakfast?
A lot of people, but I do.
And what I learned is that the key ingredient
is MSG.
Like Doritos are just coated in MSG.
What it does is it tricks your brain into
thinking that you're eating meat like some
sort of, like protein rich, delicious thing,
which is like our ancestors needed that to
survive.
And so we just love MSG and that's how you're
able to take a chip like a Dorito, which is
just like a refined corn paste that has been
smashed and then like fried and baked and
make it so delicious.
You just sprinkle some of this magic powder
on there and you have a Dorito, and I eat
Doritos for breakfast like all the time.